matt james is speaking out about the
recent controversies
involving bachelor host chris harrison
and contestant
rachel curcanelle you know what i i
absolutely did
the 29 year old bachelor lead issued a
lengthy statement on
instagram monday addressing the quote
troubling information that has surfaced
in recent weeks
and promised fans that they'll hear more
from him on the topic
controversy first erupted earlier this
month
when harrison gave an interview with
former bachelorette
rachel lindsey defending kirkenel's past
racist actions he later issued an
apology
on february 13th the longtime bachelor
host announced that he's taking time off
from the show
and will not be hosting the after the
final rose special
kerkinell also issued a statement to
apologize for her past behavior
which included attending a plantation
party when she was in college in 2018.
now james is speaking out calling the
past few weeks some of the most
challenging of his life he calls
harrison and kirkenel's actions
disappointing and adds that it has been
quote
devastating and heartbreaking the
picture was reported
from 2018 at an old south
antebellum party so i think you know
when you hold that down
well rachel is it a good look in 2018 or
is it not a good look in 2021
because there's a big deal ever james
says that harrison's interview was quote
troubling and painful to watch and adds
quote
it was a clear reflection of a much
larger issue that the bachelor franchise
has fallen short on addressing
adequately for years
however james says the moment has also
raised important questions resulting in
quote
inspiring displays of solidarity from
the bachelor nation
he says he's hopeful that this is a
turning point that causes real and
institutional change for the better
honestly
i could see them not having one at all
like should chris decide to say
i don't want to do this at all or i'm
going to leave my time is up
i could see them not doing it in a sneak
peek at wednesday's episode of the black
girls texting podcast
shared by people lindsay opens up about
what she thinks might happen to the show
going
forward and she reveals if she would
ever step
in and fill harrison's shoes honestly
i can't even i can't even go there
because one
chris has only said that he's stepping
aside and and to my
knowledge that's all that i know is that
he's not doing the finale
it's hard for me to even think about
being the host because a lot of thing in
a lot of ways bachelor nation
has changed my life in the best way
possible
but at the same time it's really toxic
and i don't know if i want to subject
myself to that
you